the following is a presentation of the
st
louis chess club
hello everyone i'm grand master dennis
borish and
i have a confession to make i didn't
really know what's going to happen
and i thought to myself oh no my podcast
it will never happen but then
suddenly out of nowhere everything
started clicking
and i've got my special guest
special guest who's actually amusing
babies you can watch and go up on social
media
they never look at the board they're
transfixed
on this youtuber photographer
and a tea drinker yes he doesn't label
himself
a streamer but a tea drinker so my
special guest is
eric rosen it's great to be here that
was a pretty
magnificent introduction appreciate that
a little bit
um sad that you're drinking water now
uh well oh that reminds me i have a few
gifts for you oh really
i brought you some tea ah
it's um it's actually tea that i
received from a
fan but they sent me like six boxes of
this oh six
one one oh and it's also spicy so do you
like spicy
tea more or more flavory
i like the diverse range of teas
this one's nice it's egyptian licorice
mint so it's a blend of like spiciness
sweetness uh
mintiness it's really nice and it's not
caffeinated you can fall asleep to it
so i got you one more gift too oh my
goodness
the gifts never i really hope that you
are medium
size i got you oh no my queen
thank you i know it's 90 degrees out but
uh
i'll try i'll try i've tried to rock
this
but thank you so much you're welcome um
so i do want to come back
because this is your self-introduction
in
most of your home pages and
why are you twitch streamer last
and ooh and tj
um i feel like most people
assume that i i stream on twitch
and less people actually most people
know that i stream and drink tea
but i feel like more people need to know
that i i drink
and enjoy tea and it's something that's
still like underrated these days like
most people like drink coffee
or energy drinks um so i'm still looking
to get like a tea
sponsorship uh because there's this
drink g-fuel they do a lot of
sponsorships for streamers a lot of just
streamers
but um i'm trying to to make a name for
myself and then
branch out exactly actually so
whenever i watch you stream
there is this very calm vibe
that you get just from being there
and getting the atmosphere and i was
looking through the coaches
you had uh just a name top of
my head a couple of them mezgan dimitri
guravich
can you tell me a little bit about them
and also
did any of them help you get this calm
demeanor which is
so uniquely you well there's mezgan mana
dimitry girovich uh tamargo lovey who is
my coach
basically from the time i was eight
through
uh like 13 14 through high school um
and they all helped with like different
aspects of my play
uh yuri shulman too actually uh former
us champion
um i'm not sure like i think i grew up
more like introverted so
being calm and quiet was more a part of
my personality
and i mean the coaches like they they
helped me get better at chess but
i think the calmness came from drinking
a lot of tea
and ah so the t is the secret
um yeah and also just streaming on
twitch like when i first started
streaming
people a lot of people would make the
comment that they fall asleep to my
streams
and i think that encouraged me further
to like be relaxing avoid making loud
noises
and um kind of embody this brand of
of relaxing but also kind of educational
family friendly
so i feel like it's uh those are nice
things to brand yourself around yeah
and it was very interesting to just
go back and go back in time because you
started before the big chess boom
how was it like to build your brand at
that time and actually when did you
start
exactly sure so i started um streaming
on twitch and then doing youtube content
regularly
back in 2017 uh right after graduating
from webster
and when i started i actually thought
the
like the twitch chess market and just
chess content overall was
was beginning to get over saturated um
but little bit i know it'll just boom
a lot more over the years especially
this past year
but i really just started as a passion
project like i wasn't
looking to make it my full-time job i
just wanted to
put myself out there do some some
educational content
build an audience um i actually started
a little bit before
before i did like twitch and youtube
regularly i did
the residency position at singapore
chess club and a lot of my videos
got popular a lot a lot of the opening
videos london video
grand prix video so i think that was a
kickstart
and made me realize that there's a
demand for chess content
and of course like over the last year
especially last couple years
things have grown beyond my wildest
expectations but i'm super grateful to
be doing what i love it's very
interesting because
you did all of that branching into
twitch but you also started doing
photography and i wonder which one was
first your love for creating pictures
and even thumbnails some of your
thumbnails
are very artistic so if you thought
oh i'm watching eric rosen what
an artistic chess player he is well look
at take a look at his thumbnails yeah
um definitely the design and
photography interests came way before
i was interested in streaming um i got
into like photoshop and photography
around
i guess 20 20 what was that 2009.
so i was a freshman in high school and
um
it was it was a fun hobby like i did
photos from
for my high school yearbook i was a
design editor so
did a lot of photoshop and um i like
i like manipulating images to make them
look cool so
it was a great fit into like making
content for youtube doing my own
thumbnails
um and still to this day i do almost all
my my youtube thumbnails
um so it's nice kind of break from the
chess and have a
different type of creative outlets
what was the question again so really i
was curious
if having an affinity towards
photography helped you grow
both both as a twitch streamer and
you know as a person as a whole yeah um
and there's not too many people that
have this overlapping interest
of photography and chess uh there's a
few notable people like leonard
leonard david yatta a bunch of others
too
but um it was uh it's kind of an overlap
that
not too many people share so i have
opportunity
i guess college and after college to be
a like mean photographer a lot of events
st louis a lot of national events
um i don't know if you know this but in
a couple of weeks i'm going to sochi
oh for the world cup i was actually
invited to be the official photographer
congrats which is going to be a change
of pace from what i've been doing
uh the last year um so i'll be upgrading
my camera equipment very soon
um so it's been great like it's it's a
nice uh
nice balance and it's cool to kind of
capture the moment
um and it's it's not like a competitive
activity so you just take photos and
um enjoy the final product so a bit like
that
vibe that you anyways like to create
yeah yeah and i think like
i guess you could argue there's some
like creative overlap between chess and
photography
maybe not the same as like chess and
other sports
but the concept of like thinking outside
the box looking for
um concepts or angles that people
haven't like tried before
and uh yeah it's super fun so
i want to let everyone know this is an
interactive interview so if you have a
question of your
own on youtube or twitch you are welcome
to ask your questions to eric
and we'll be happy to relay it to him
also uh you've been meeting them the
first time
since the world is opening up you've
been to vegas
how was your experience meeting your
fans live yeah it was super cool
um i was in vegas a week and a half ago
for a national open
and there were 1000 to 1500 chess
players and it was
basically the first in like major
in-person events
to come back after like so many things
shut down
it was really well organized uh playing
hall was really nice round started on
time
um i was very surreal
also humbling to like just get stopped
by so many people who watched my content
on twitch and uh and youtube and got a
lot of requests
for taking selfies with people and
signing autographs
um i got stopped by one person
who wanted to take a picture of me
because i was actually wearing this
shirt
yeah this is my my merch people can find
it online but
um i thought he was a fan like older guy
like
excited to meet me so i posed for the
photo and after
he took the photo like um i realized he
had no idea who i was
he just liked my shirt so um that was
that was an interesting experience but
uh
yeah i got to meet a lot of people who
i've never met before in real life but
like know them
on twitch so a lot of people introduced
me by their twitch username
um it's really cool to see like the
diversity
of of people and players who watch my
content
um there were a lot of kids like the
kids would come up and then just be
starstruck and not know what to say
and then i wouldn't know what to say so
i was fan struck but usually like
parents would take a picture of us uh
then there were older people too
like a few of my longtime subscribers uh
in their like 60s or 70s so it's it's
really cool to kind of reach a broad
range of people
and talking about old and new friends
so you took a picture and
found one of your pictures in the
archives about none other
from gotham chess levy rosman
which was taken in new york back in what
time
what day oh you're referring to the
upside down upside down
apartment in new york in january 2020
so before everything really shut down
and i remember like we were both like
active on twitch
and he was he wasn't doing much youtube
like he had less than a thousand
subscribers i think when i
stayed there in january i remember like
trying to convince him oh you should
start doing more youtube there's a lot
of opportunity
um and several months later like i think
he started more regularly in
may or june and now surpassed a million
subscribers so
it's amazing to see yeah and uh i think
i kind of view him as a role model
mentor but we kind of help each other
too like we
we talk every so often about like how um
how the landscape has changed and kind
of new ideas going forward
so looking back retrospectively
and of course if you can share some
secrets
in this respect
what changed and what were like those
breakout opportunities
that were possible back then when you
just started
that are not really as possible these
days oh when i first started
yeah um it's hard to identify like a
breakout opportunity it was more like a
slow
gradual grind like when i started
streaming on twitch it was to
like less than five viewers maybe a few
of them being me like opening the stream
on new tabs
so a lot of it was just trying to enjoy
the process
and make content that i enjoy that
viewers enjoy
and doing it on a consistent basis um
yeah looking back i don't think there
was a a particular
like inflection points it's more about
the
the everyday grind and consistency and
i think what helped me was just doing
very regular content both on twitch and
then on youtube
because twitch it's a live interaction
but then youtube
um people can watch whenever so they
don't have to
be there be there at the moment to watch
so
a lot of my earlier streams i just put
on youtube and then reach whole whole
different audience and then they would
carry over to twitch so
a lot of it was about leveraging kind of
the different platforms
uh to to provide value to the audience
and then
to kind of cross-promote between mainly
twitch and youtube
and of course like using leachates and
chess.com too
i've streamed pretty regularly on the
chess and they put me on their homepage
after maybe a month of me streaming so
that really helped
kind of appeal to the the chess players
that existed online
so i guess the community building just
mattered a lot
yeah yeah there's there's different
things like i did
maybe kind of instinctively looking back
on it was like good social media
strategy
of uh of kind of using my twitch content
putting on on youtube
um getting people to like engage on the
chess
making leachat studies and then
providing like opening traps and
um and doing a lot of evergreen content
too
uh it's actually one thing i learned
from doing videos for st louis
if i do a video on an opening that could
still be popular
many years later opening traps don't
really go out of fashion like the rules
aren't changing
too much so um or we don't know about it
just yet
right yeah so like with youtube if you
if you do a video on an evergreen
concept that can that can really benefit
you years down the road and
um i think that like some of the early
videos i did helped
also bring audience from the st louis
chess club over to my content too
and then vice versa so um it was a
win-win for everyone yeah
i also want to talk a little bit about
this chess boom the queen's gambit pog
champs
provided by chess.com i wanted to
ask you were you surprised to see
the cross uh range of people who like
you like
60s and 70s year old people
political scientists reaching out to you
were you surprised how did you approach
to demographics that you were surprised
to see or were you surprised at all
yeah sometimes it doesn't like fully
sink in like how many different people
watch my content because it's all
it's all virtual like i just see
usernames in chat so a lot of it is just
me trying to play chess and talk through
my moves
and engage uh engage when i can
um but i guess it is it's super humbling
to
to know that like there's so many
different demographics
um i think
uh what was i gonna say um
like what is the question like yeah uh
so
um oh i know it was yesterday sorry okay
um
lost my train of thought but it really
helps to uh
to stay out of politics and controversy
um like you mentioned political
scientists but i i
try and not get into drama
i know like it's it's interesting i mean
you did get a fight with a duck
i think it was a goose but you're
starting a war here it was flight or
fight i chose flight flight yeah i don't
think
yeah you're right actually you're right
it's a goose yeah
um so i try not to be too
violent um at least off the chessboard
on the chessboard i love to attack and
sacrifice and everything
um but yeah it's nice to
to try and be as wholesome as possible
um
and when when the geese chase me i i
just try and run away and
not get hurt so talking about a fight or
flight
it's very interesting your way of
playing chess is
so much different than what you see in
more competitive channels like hikarus
and the chess bras
they're more like i've got to win um
if there's a solution that is
interesting they're not emphasizing it
as much they're like oh this is
interesting
and they move on unlike you
you kind of accentuate if drama is
happening and especially
your famous rosen trap when
you're setting up the drama so
just let me give you a preview he's in
big trouble
doesn't have many pieces left even down
a queen
at times and with
15 seconds to a minute and
what he does he waits till the last
second
and not capturing the queen completely
shocking and flabbergasting the opponent
and then they stalemate so is this
instinctive
or so kind of
natural well the first ever time i did
it
you may have been watching live it was a
pro chess league
2018 um i think we were playing
argentina i was playing from london
and i lost my first three games we
played four total the final game i was
getting smashed
um but i wasn't resigning uh and the
opponent was clearly like just torturing
me like taking all my pawns and
eventually it was like i had king and
rook versus queen and bunch of pawns
um and i like kind of stumbled into it
where
like um opponent took my rook on g6 and
instead of taking back the queen i play
king h8s
they were expecting me to take the queen
so they pre-moved upon move and then it
was just stalemates
and then since getting it the first time
i realized
this this is a trap that you can get
relatively often like compared to other
especially end game traps
like we know of opening traps how common
those can be but end game traps
quite rare like the same ones don't
occur on a regular basis but this was
one
which i think is unique to online chess
because it takes advantage
of kind of the psychology of pre-moving
and yeah since getting it in that game
i've done it
many many times i have a whole youtube
channel dedicated to
my clips it's called eric rosenclips
it's my second uh second channel
and uh if you if you search for it like
stalemate trap you'll find a bunch of
the clips
to uh to watch so i actually have like a
clip channel suggestion people
who were inspired by you doing the
rosentrap
because actually there is a clip
that is posted on twitter by jo brun
who's also a streamer
i saw that one and he does the exact
same trap and does it perfectly i'm
pretty sure he did it like two days in a
row too i retweeted him
um but yeah it would be really cool to
make a compilation of like my own traps
plus
the traps that other people get i know
neridsky had one and like
he he thanked me after getting it um
i forgot to mention i trapped hikaru
with that too and a game of choker
which was which was fun he didn't really
appreciate it i don't think too much but
uh yeah it goes to show you can never uh
you should never resign too early yeah
and it's just really great like
i saw uh joe do this trap and i've seen
people having fun playing chess because
a lot of times
originally or what i saw from youtube
and on twitter and
twitch is that everyone is very
competitive
and they don't focus on the fun part
so i just saw that you inspired
indonesian streamers just to join the
fray
and i saw them play hand and brain and
they had
more fun that i've seen in like these
high titled arenas ah yeah ever
well this is the nature of twitch like
you can there's so many different types
of content ideas you can do with
other streamers that are more
collaborative and less competitive and
um in the end of the day it's about
having fun and enjoying the game
i think you may have been referring to
irene uh yes good friend of mine
chelsea monica right chelsea too
and it's cool that they're they're like
getting the attention of a whole
a whole other like audience um in
indonesia and um yeah it's super cool
and we're seeing a lot more streamers
kind of collaborate with each other
try out different ideas between hand and
brain blindfold chess
doing sub battles viewer tournaments so
it's a great
a great age to to play play chess
especially online
i'm actually very happy with that clip
and love to see
more of that in the future because um
as we all know um it is still
more of a male dominated sport but more
and
more and more girls get interested in
the game
due to the queen's gambit and of the
online presence
so what do you think of that what do you
think this whole movement with the
queen's gambit will go to
yeah i mean i think the queen's gamut
alone has
i hope has inspired many more women to
women girls to play chess
um i'm not sure how easy it would be to
actually track
the statistics of what impact it had
um the one stat that comes to mind is
what levy shared gotham chess
like during the whole queen's gambit
hype he made a video on how to play
chess
and i'm pretty sure the video had like
30 to 40 percent
female viewership which uh is actually a
huge amount like in the chess niche
because
uh like my my channel average and many
other chess channel
averages usually like 97 98
mil two to three percent female um
so levy was able to make a video kind of
bringing chess to the
the other gender which i think we we
need to see more of and um
it's great that it's becoming more
accessible and um these days we're
seeing a lot of
uh a lot of like women's tournaments and
a lot more like
strong female players so hopefully the
trend continues yeah i actually was
thinking about that myself
that uh it'd be great to
kind of help and just provide
opportunities
for girls and women to play because a
lot of times
um the main events are
slated towards high-rated people and uh
you know oftentimes uh they don't have
categories
where are you doing uh in your channel
uh tournaments based on categories
or where you think about it can you give
me an example
categories is that you can play under
2000 section
under 1300 section because a lot of
times
how i think people get dissuaded and it
goes both for
boys and girls is that you don't feel
that you're in competition you're not
enjoying
uh the whole fight aspect and
um a lot of times i feel that that's
when girls decide that i'm not
interested anymore
because i'm not competitive i'm not
having that fun that i used to have
yeah um and this can apply to anyone
where like
in order to have fun you want to have
some balance between winning and losing
um online these days uh
one thing i really like we we don't i
i personally don't do uh tournaments
where there's different rating sections
but i do host a lot of arena tournaments
where the algorithm is such that
you'll play players um close to your
rating
um and this is usually the case i know
leachates and chess.com do it
differently
on lead chess you you might like play a
few games lose a few but then you'll
play
other people in your your kind of score
group
and then chess.com i think just pairs
you based on reading
so that uh like the the pairing
algorithms i think are
are adapting to to try and just get more
people
to have a better experience which is is
nice to see a very good thing
um of course like when we talk about
over-the-board chess that's a bit
different and
most open tournaments will have the
different rating sections and then
you can choose what section you want to
play um sometimes i recommend like
playing a section above your level even
though you're expected to lose more
you can learn more and see what the next
level is like so yeah i kind of agree
with that one exactly because um
not long ago there was a pan
am championship with boys and girls
together and of course a girl one
because it's not really the gender that
matters
but the rating average and if you are
competitive at that level
so in that event everyone was near 2200
ish
and the winner was also with the same
range so uh
oftentimes what i realized and i don't
want to make this obviously too
political
is that when you do actually
push yourself and try to keep pace
with the stronger ones and higher rated
ones
you eventually assimilate enough
experience to play at that level
yeah um i can speak from personal
experience that when i was younger
and i was at a level where i i could
play in scholastic tournaments but
i preferred playing more open
tournaments most opportunities i had i
would play up a section
um just to learn more and i think you
can you can grow more quickly especially
if you have the right mindset
to play to learn and like review every
single game that you play which
i was doing consistently with coaches so
that
that can help accelerate the learning
process and i think a big
problem a lot of people have these days
not just in chess but other sports too
is you become so fixated on reading or
winning or just getting the the title
and you kind of become
detached from the learning process so
it's important to
take a step back and see the big picture
and do things that will help in the
long term yeah and i want to talk a
little bit about
norms and how that worked for you or how
you got them
um also i want to add my little bit
of the norms they often ask me to when
i'm online and when i'm
coaching why did you become a gm or
did you have a plan to become a gm and i
always tell them
i just wanted to be competitive i really
just want to
keep pace with my rivals it never really
was
my goal uh to become a gm and what was
your goal of uh getting norms and
uh well we can talk about present my
presence philosophy or like yeah
which whichever you want to talk about
i'll start with like the question i get
probably most often
is when you want to become a gm when are
you going to become a gm
um and like what what i'm doing to work
towards the next title
uh and my my honest answer is that it's
not my primary goal
obviously it's like the next level above
i am um
so a lot of people assume that i'll get
it eventually
but there's a there's a very big gap
between
fm and im im and gm and it can take
years and years of full
dedication to gain um to get the norms
get the rating
and even then like there is no guarantee
a lot of people
hit roadblocks and its um it's not like
a straight uh straight line let me just
break the pattern
because everyone is oh when are you
going to take another step forward
but you did take a huge step forward
from
the fm category to the i am so can you
tell us a little bit about that
yeah so i so in high school
i i got to like 23 2400
um us ratings so around 2300 feet a
and i plateaued for about four years
where okay i was still studying still
playing play all my high school college
teams
um but didn't really make the next jump
and then in the span of like two or
three tournaments i gained 100 points
got my actually my third and fourth i am
norm like
back to back tournaments got the 2400
feet a rating
um i think this is a typical experience
where you plateau for a while
it doesn't necessarily mean you're
stagnating like you're not improving it
just means that it takes a while for
your rating to catch up to your actual
ability
and you you need to you need to be in
the right form to like play high-level
chess so you can have good understanding
but
you you need the engine to be working
well um
so this was this was kind of a
breakthrough point so i got
i am title this was back in 2015. um
and then i guess shortly after getting
the title
i um i was attending webster and
made the realization that i don't
necessarily want to
become a professional chess player and i
wanted to diversify
my skill sets so i put more time into
coaching doing freelance work kind of
pursuing
not necessarily academics like i wasn't
i'll admit i wasn't the best student in
school but i was very passionate about
kind of learning things on my own
doing a lot of uh kind of
self-exploration like online videos
online tutorials
learned a lot from youtube um so i think
that was a worthwhile
investment of my time of course there's
a sacrifice from
maybe not studying as much chess towards
the end of my my college days
but um i think it helped kind of put me
in the spot where i am today where i was
able to kind of pivot into
becoming a chess educator streamer i'm
still passionate about learning it's
just i'm not
uh i'm not solely focused on getting the
the gm title
all right so after all these questions
let's open it up for the chat let's see
um
hey eric when is your rap song coming up
oh dear
um well for those who don't know levy
put out a rap song
when he hit a million subscribers this
was last month
so maybe when i hit a million
subscribers i have to hit up
levy's producers have them drop a beat
and uh yeah let's say when i hit a
million hopefully within like a year or
two
okay so let's keep the questions rolling
um let's see there was a question on
twitch is there a video of the stalemate
trap
and we do have a link from the one and
only vampire chicken
uh sharing the stalemate trap
compilation
uh which i believe is on my eclipse
channel but you can just search for it
on youtube too there's uh there's a
bunch of videos
okay i see some other questions uh
i don't know what this word means um do
you know what this means
no but looks very interesting i'm always
scared of of saying words i don't know
what they mean because sometimes people
troll me
well sometimes you just have to
experience
i think they does it mean perplexed it
could be perplexed
how about of course i perplexed my
opponents
um let's move on to an easier question
bishops are knights bishops are knights
uh i say it depends on the position
um also depends on the time control so
bishops
are better in open positions and usually
slower time controls
knights are better in close positions
and faster time controls because they're
trickier
also i wanted to ask you who is your
favorite opponent
playing online like fun wise
who is the most fun to play against it's
gotta be magnus magnus
one man i don't think there's there's no
opponent that's
brought me like so many views um
like that no one competes with magnus
because when i play him like the videos
just get so many views and
the games are also like really
interesting uh
the first time i played him i didn't
realize that i was playing him until
afterwards um i beat him like
it was a lee chess title arena he was
playing from his phone but
i still managed to get a win position
yeah and then a few months later um of
course i posted the video on youtube
like the next day
a few months later that video was shared
on reddit it made the front page got
like 40 50 000 upvotes
um so that was really cool and i beat
him again like
a year later in some 960 game but then
he beat me a couple times
my most recent game with him i tried to
play a staffer and
it kind of went wrong but yeah i have a
whole playlist on my youtube channel of
my games against magnus
so any tennis or
photography lately that's what
um the chat is asking uh
yes photography came more recent than
tennis
i did play tennis the other day with um
with dominguez oh wow um and then ray
ray robson how does this serve i'm
always concerned when i
hear tennis i mean chess players play
tennis
how does this serve is it good well okay
so especially a super gm you expect them
to be really good at chess but you
might not think they'd have time to do
much tennis
but dominguez was actually he's probably
the best
super gm tennis player um he did manage
to ace me once
oh um which like i usually don't get ace
like i'm i'm decent at like at least
getting contact on the ball even though
mark esterman is
not yet a super gm yeah would he compete
against dominguez
yeah azerman would just i don't think it
would even be competition like
he could probably be a good coach for
okay for us mortals
asterman's like a different level um
which i i do aspire to play with
herman at some point but uh yeah
dominguez had like a very
very decent game like very consistent
uh very dangerous neck play he had a lot
of like crazy like volleys and
winners so um i was super impressed
and then the second part of that was
photography
um i'll admit like during the course of
pandemic i wasn't doing much photography
but a few days ago one of my best
friends proposed
um and the way we set it up
is we did a photo shoot um
him and his soon-to-be fiancee uh or
soon to be fiance just thought it was a
photo shoot so we walked around the city
uh just taking photos and then and he
proposed so it was uh it was pretty cool
um i don't think we have those photos to
share
for for today uh talking about irl
and streamers so it's very interesting
some of you might not know but
tennis is pretty big in the chess
community so many big
chess players have played tennis even
historically karpov
and many others have been playing tennis
for quite a while
and uh loyo sportish from hungary who is
a multiple
time hungarian champion and olympic
champion was a big swimmer
so i'm very curious do you think
we're going to have a tennis slash chess
tournament ever irl we should i think
it's a great idea
yeah do some yeah do the mental battle
the physical battle
um i have to brainstorm some formats for
that
but yeah i've um i mean
i guess this was already a couple years
ago but when there's these major
tournaments in st louis
i have played with hikaru fabi mvl kazim
jhanov
so it's cool to see like all these top
gm's just
out on the tennis court and um they're
all better than you would expect
so yeah interestingly enough i've never
heard nor seen kasparov play on tennis
but i hope chat will know drag him to
the tennis courts
yeah well if he is willing that's right
also um apart from that
if you would get the chance um would you
play
in an irl irl streamer tournament
where it's exclusively streamers if
you're not a streamer
sorry now when you say irl of course
that means in real life
in real life would it be on a physical
chestnut not a physical
of course of course yeah that would be
cool just invite
all the all the streamers to st louis
have the dgt
boards do the broadcast you can do
comments or you can play but
there can be commentary in the studio
too the problem with that is like who
would you commentary
well at the moment like i just say
streamers playing chess live
but if you think about it the whole
chess community
has been streaming by now so it would be
almost like almost like a
huge arena you know who i don't think
has started streaming at least on
personal channels yasser true need to
get him starting to stream
i saw him active in the chat the other
day um
i saw him actually the other day like he
told me he lurks in his
in my chat um and he was in katarina's
chat uh recently
so i have to get him to start a twitch
channel but
maybe he could do commentary for an
event like that yeah i mean
that'd be soothing and moving too yeah
so yeah um very interesting
um that kind of reminds me
of are you planning to play more
tournaments i
saw you played a couple of games in
vegas but are you planning to play some
more
i played eight games in vegas eight
games yeah i took one by oh yeah i just
saw
that went by so that was probably a
moment i just didn't see you play
um yeah i definitely want to like i'm
not retired from motherboard chess
and the vegas tournament i decided like
i signed up the day before
i was going back and forth like do i
just go and enjoy myself
not have to play and see fans or do i
actually throw myself in the event
and i'm happy i played i i feel like i
was in decent form for not having played
in a year and a half
there is some rust there is some
confidence issues
but uh yeah i definitely want to play
again in some nice
um it would have to be a nice location
like i'd be open to playing in st
louis um i definitely want to play in
reykjavik
uh maybe next year for the reykjavik
open uh
last year i wanted to play in vietnam
for the hd bank
in march it's a big event of course all
of that fell through
um so yeah it'd be cool to to play some
more
serious otb chess but i mean my next
event
is in russia in sochi but i'm not
playing i'm just photographing so that
will be
a bit less stressful and are you
planning to
talk about sochi are you planning to
visit some big events
so if you're unfamiliar dear viewer
there
is going to be big events in san
francisco which
is slated to be the finals for the
magnus tour
and of course in august we have the st
louis rapidan blitz here in the singles
chess club and the sink world cup of
course
yep yeah i'll definitely be in st louis
in august
uh i think i'll be helping out with the
club during the st louis wrapping blitz
so that should be really cool um i kind
of want to go to dubai
to see the the nepo magnus world
championship
do you have any hot takes that we can
write down
and then use your tips um
i just want to see like interesting
fighting chess okay i'm hoping for
not all draws which i think is more
likely compared to last uh
yeah i think that's a good bet yeah for
this one
yeah and then when is the the event in
san francisco
san francisco um i don't have
the exact date um they still have a
couple of
more events going on because their
qualification is
just happening at the moment as they're
playing at
the asian leg of that tour
so i'm not quite sure they're still uh
qualifying
gotcha moment i guess the other one that
comes to mind is u.s champs
and yeah i think october so i should be
in town for that
and it's nice that over-the-board chess
is returning you can see people in real
life
and uh and and play chess in the third
dimension
um and by the way i do want to ask you a
little bit about
uh the your
inspirations in twitch and youtube
uh who inspired you first in youtube
and then on twitch um i mean i gotta
give shout outs to some of the ogs
like john bartholomew chastra chess
network
um i'm trying to think like who who
started streaming
like before 2017 maybe botez started a
few months before me
so um there was already
there were already like some some
regular like chess content creators
who who started really early that made
like really cool content
i was a big fan of john bartholomew's
content like i watch him to learn
and see how he not only how he plays and
learn um like learn his own thought
process but also learn his teaching
process like he
communicates very clearly has a great
kind of video series on
chess fundamentals which i think he made
like
five six years ago but um
it still gets views because it's uh it's
amazing content
um so
i guess there's people i understand what
oh
actually siri strikes again
um so interestingly enough
eric often gets into trouble with siri
i do siri is always after you well
seriously what did you do
i i i say words and it thinks
it's saying like i'm saying its name and
then it starts listening
and then it just doesn't understand so
sometimes i have to silence it
just like a true family member never
understands
it's uh yeah it's it's okay it keeps me
company sometimes
um i was gonna say uh apart from like
the chess
content creators that inspired me um
in college i was really inspired by
i guess three like kind of mainstream
like i guess influencers that are not
chess related but more like business and
self-help
uh one being gary vaynerchuk um
like a business person entrepreneur does
a lot of like kind of
self-development and social media
strategy content
um so i went through a phase of just
watching his videos and trying to apply
like kind of his philosophy
to my own work um another one is tim
ferriss
um he has a ton of books on like
self-improvement
a four-hour workweek is a great one
about kind of lifestyle design
and how to be your own boss
and then maybe more recently is matt
diabella who has a youtube channel
more in the self-development niche
focuses a lot on like minimalism
and habits and routines and i think
between these three people i've learned
a ton about
how to kind of structure my uh my
personal and business life
i do have to ask because i'm curious um
when you talk about minimalism does it
have a bit of connection with stoicism
or not so much um
there might be some connection um
actually tim ferriss talks more about
stoicism
and there's there's there's different
layers of each um
but then then there's another ism
there's essentialism
i just uh actually just finished a good
audiobook
it's called essentialism by greg mckeown
really good book about it's kind of
another layer
to minimalism but focusing on things
that are essential
and kind of cutting out uh the things
that are not essential in life so it's a
very good listen
i mean that kind of uh
i was just thinking about it right now
that
we've got the more emotional streamers
eric hansen
hikaru even alexandra votes let's put
her there
sometimes she does get emotional if
it's not the first queen that wanders
off the board
but yeah now as you mentioned john
barcelona
he does have this cool demeanor when
he's playing when he's explaining
he's very upset yeah i think he
actually had some impact on
on what i wanted to embody um like him
and
jerry chess network where were streamers
i looked
up to in the whole kind of branding
regard
um as i also forgot to mention ben
feingold oh of course
um i would just binge his videos like i
i would
just watch his videos before i went to
sleep because he used to do like all the
um the lectures in st with chess club
like he was a permanent resident
um before it became a rotating position
um
so like his humor also kind of inspired
me and
um yeah it's nice like when you're
especially when you're in some field to
kind of see what else is out there
look at people that are similar and
different and see what
what types of things that you want to
kind of get inspired from
so uh before we're told
uh we're heading towards the end i want
to see
any last questions
do you even lift bro uh
that actually reminds me i have a
workout thing
in like half hour so i'm gonna have to
go soon
i'll probably do some lifting bro
um so yeah it's one of the things that i
i should do more of especially after the
last year of
not going to the gym but uh
and maybe playing more chess on physical
boards i'll lift some rooks
do you miss lifting uh rooks
um i was lifting rooks last night
on the stream but two dimensionally so
it's a bit different
not as strenuous on the muscles yeah
um what is your favorite tea oh
you can show it this is one of my
favorites i have a lot of favorite teas
these days
but egyptian licorice mint it's a gift
to dennis for today
i have a whole if you go to my twitch
chat and use the exclamation point tea
you'll find a list of tea
recommendations that i enjoy
so uh before we end i wanted to ask this
question
if you ever get a chance would you do
sponsored arenas
in your streams or youtube or whichever
you
when you say sponsored arenas that can
just be sponsored content right
yeah sponsored content yes yeah um i've
done a few
a few sponsor like kind of brand deal
sponsorship type things
um one of the more recent ones was a
deal with audible
where i basically give them a 60 second
shout out in youtube video
give people a link to uh to
like a free audiobook and um it's a
product that i've been using for a while
i am very particular in what sort of
deals i want to
promote like there are certain things
that um
i i don't get into like i got a deal
from a whiskey company that
had to turn down and then
there's a lot like i get messages very
very frequently of like
brand deal offers but i am very
selective and
i'll probably do some more coming up um
but it's it's a balance of trying to
focus on the chest but also
like when the right thing comes along to
to integrate it in the best way
um so i did launch i shouldn't mention i
launched merch which is kind of my own
oh no my queen is slightly sponsored um
so people can go to
shop.imrozen.com i launched it
over a month ago but the launch coupon
code still works for 10 percent off
um and you got your free merch somewhere
i hope you didn't use it yet no
is hiding but it's still here nice so
eric thank you so much for being part of
this show and
hope to see you in the future appreciate
it it's been a pleasure take care
everyone
hope you had a good time bye bye
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club
you